Virginia by the way also elected one of
the first publicly transgender
candidates in the country Democrat
Danica roham Danica roam is a man who
has transitioned to look like a woman
over Republican Bob Marshall very
socially conservative candidate who had
put forward a bathroom bill the bathroom
bill you know those awful terrible
bigoted laws that say that men should
use the men's room and women should use
the women's room here here is a clip of
that candidate Danica roam because well
now of trans woman who can finally fixed
route 28 I spent nine years two months
and two weeks as the lead reporter the
Gainesville Times car my home community
is about time that the administration in
particular and other people start
trash-talking reporters and start
respecting the craft because local
journalism is community service it is
public service and the people of the
13th district just supported to elect
and sent a reporter down to Richmond
I'll always be a reporter before
non-politician on the trans part there
yeah I am a transgender woman we won
because I am a transgender room because
I am a reporter because I am a lifelong
medicare's M&S because of my I had
inherent identifiers not despite them I
never ran away from them I championed
them and because of that yeah Prince
William County is no is now more
inclusive than it was you
there it is I'm actually really shocked
it's really a sad loss in the culture
war obviously that the voters of
Virginia would consider electing a
journalist to any office really
upsetting that's not good any anybody
who's worked in in news like that is
just by definition disqualified from
holding any office in government it is a
little strange obviously that if for
those who can't see the clip there
obviously this person is a man who
dresses like a woman and has long hair
we had Blair white friend of the show
came on a few weeks ago and said gender
dysphoria is clearly a mental illness
it's a psychological affliction
although mental illness is probably a
prerequisite for holding political
office anyway so that doesn't bother me
too much but all of this to say it
doesn't seem to me a shock that a state
that elected a man who looks like a
woman basically on the platform of
looking like a woman would would not
vote for george w bush's Republican
National Committee Chairman Ed Gillespie
this is not you know earth-shattering
stuff here there is also another point
to consider which is the Democrats are
less popular according to a recent poll
than they have been in 25 years then
they've been in a quarter of a century
I'm a little torn on this CNN just did
this poll and they found out the
Democrat approval ratings down to about
30 percent the lowest in a quarter of a
century but if CNN is reporting it then
doesn't it mean that that is fake news
and Democrats are very popular
I don't know I'm caught in a real
paradox here according to this poll
thirty thirty seven percent of Americans
hold a favorable view of Democrats this
is down from forty five percent in March
a precipitous drop it's down from 62
percent the day that Barack Obama was
elected the first time doesn't seem to
me a random chance or a random
coincidence that the high point of
Democratic popularity was the day Barack
Obama was elected it's been sliding down
steadily ever since Republicans are also
unpopular now they're about thirty or
thirty one percent but the thing to
point out here is over that same period
Republicans have never been higher than
forty eight percent approval
yet they have one massive victories and
elections across the country so I it's
one has to wonder what that says about
public approval ratings according to
these opinion bowls for Democrats versus
what they say about Republicans
Republicans have been able to win major
victories during this point Democrats
not so much we'll see if this election
of Virginia and New Jersey has any
anything to say about the upcoming
elections